one two three
four too far
there hi i'm becky and welcome to build
it blind
today we are going to be making sundays
i've got my trusty coach teddy
there i got you becky there
and he's gonna help me build a sundae
the only catch is once i touch something
i gotta eat it
all right becky here we go we're gonna
do this with your left hand
reach straight forward wait close your
thumb close your thumb there you go
straight forward keep going bam
i believe that's the ice cream oh yeah
bring that towards you
okay okay you got it cold awesome okay
good
all right so with your with your right
hand reach a little forward there's an
empty bowl there
i'm going there right there it is that's
it you got it okay
grab it bring it towards you okay is
there a spoon somewhere you there's a
scooper on the
on the bow on your left hand there you
go there's a scooper
let's get a couple scoops in there
that you got it nope it fell off i could
feel that this isn't funny stop laughing
at me
there we go that's that's somewhat of a
scoop for you
keep going i'm gonna get you a good
scoop teddy you got it
uh there we go let's do
one more a couple more a couple yeah wow
man you know
i do ice cream sundae the bowl feels oh
god damn it
can you squeeze the ice cream scooper
that way it'll fall down
okay did it work yeah let's do that it's
my ice cream scooper face
it's not up to even facing the right
direction you're fine
you're fine yeah i'm already panicked
okay
perfect that's that's a nice scoop right
there
okay something tells me i didn't get the
bowl a couple of times okay um
okay i think we're good i think we can
move on perfect can i just put this
where slide that forward
forward yeah straight forward afraid to
touch anything it's okay just slide it
all the way through
you're clear bingo all right how does
some strawberry slime i like
strawberries
all right that's gonna be a challenge oh
gosh so
with your right hand without
dragging it reach okay maybe like a claw
machine
and you let me know you got it keep
going keep going keep going to your
right
down right there there bingo
those are strawberries oh they they feel
like strawberry i'm just doing this
sorry teddy i washed my hands first
oh there's blueberries down there oh
there's just like a good mixed berries
okay cool good that's perfect we got we
got a little bit of everything
now how does a banana sound like like a
lot of potassium
let's do some bananas then all right
with your right hand
uh there you go to your right keep going
down down down no no no up up up and
then like down closer to you
there we go to your right a little bit
more
down down there we go let's get some
bananas in there
those don't feel very nice what do we
have here got some sprinkles
we got sprinkles yeah that's right cool
let's do some sprinkles
left hand oh good this hand's ready to
go all right perfect
uh to your left keep going keep going
how big is this table close your fingers
closer to you closer to you to you pull
your hand back to you
towards you there you go now to your
left oh god what did i just touch
that's not bad that's fine it's like
it's a good okay mix we're good okay
it's oh okay all right let's head back
to the same direction
okay now to your left keep going left
this is my line there you go down down
closer to you closer to you closer that
way there you go now go down
to your right there's nothing there
teddy keep on to your right
left right this way boom bingo okay
those are some sprinkles i think oh
these are those are sprinkles
that's a lot of sprinkles love it
love it all right how about some
chocolate syrup oh does it have it does
it have a thing in it so that i don't
have to touch it
yes it's in the squeeze bottle okay but
wait hold on you have to be careful okay
because i think
there's some booby traps here oh god my
hand
it looks like we have strawberry jam or
like strawberry jelly
caramel chocolate syrup maybe
but then there's two oh god one of them
is like ketchup or
something one might be there's also one
that looks like soy sauce
all right so let's just do it left hand
left hand
all right let's go forward
okay to your left forward a little bit
okay what is that i hope that's
chocolate syrup
it smells like chocolate where's the
very good i'm so sorry forever to clean
up after this
perfect do you like a lot of chocolate
yeah let's do some chalk there we go
okay wait you're missing the bowl oh
wait okay
here's the bowl there we go all right
all right i think we're good
thank you just gonna put this that's oh
what is that what did you just touch i
don't know how you what
what did i just touch this yes what is
this i don't know you tell me i don't
like the way it feels is that if this is
bugs i'm gonna be real unhappy yo is
that
ramen i think we're doing ramen
you just did some fusion sundaes here
that's fine fusion is in right now cool
fantastic a little bit of crunch i've
seen worse on chopped let's pretend it's
peanuts it's fine
as long as it's not like crickets all
right i see
in our upper right it could be either
cream like sour cream or whipped cream
i mean here's a 5050 toss-up let's do it
let's risk it
and bet it all alex let's see right hand
left right
all right all the way four out there we
go okay
down up yeah whatever that is
this yeah i hope that's whipped cream
no it's not mayo oh god oh i didn't even
think about
i don't know how to do this all right
here's the edge of the bowl
bring the whole bowl with you okay
i'm not gonna smell it because i just
don't want to know how bad this is
i don't think this is whipped cream it's
too thick
okay oh it's not whipped cream i promise
okay that's enough you know
i'm committed it's a true daily double
it's not whipped cream let's do some
some sour worms how's that nice oh yeah
okay all right right hand
all right let's stretch out a little bit
okay now
bring it to your right scoot it to your
right bingo down down down down down
down
there you go yeah okay these are
definitely sour worms
this your dream sundae you know what i
mean do you like a little caramel on it
i do
all right cool left hand let's do it
left hand left hands four
stretch out there you go to your left
down there it is oh
you know i've touched anything now
oh that's not good
oh geez know
i don't know what that is but it was not
caramel sauce is that hot sauce
oh it is oh that smells really good
right i mean sure yeah i can do a little
hot sauce
oh all right let's see what do we have
let's do something with this hand
because i licked this hand and that's
not cool was that your left hand yeah
so let's use the right okay let's do
your right hand let's do
sorry okay stretch out with your right
hand
okay now bring it towards your left go
left with it okay
now bring it in towards you bring it in
towards you
to your right down there it is
oh are these maybe crushed oreos no
not crushed oreos are you are you
messing me up teddy no no this is like
graham crackers
okay it looks like ground quick graham
crackers okay swear to god
okay cool i think we have i think we
have it all i think we have a little bit
of everything
should have called it before the caramel
sauce
i'm happy i mean i'm not happy
all right becky good job here's some
favorite towels thank you
oh god i'm scared here's another one
yeah you're gonna need it
i'm gonna oh all right ready yeah
oh not too bad right
that is definitely hot sauce but it
could have been worse yeah we
i that's ketchup that looked like jelly
to me they look like like a strawberry
jam or like a strawberry
i think hot sauce is way better than
ketchup yeah definitely i'll take that
there we go to our creation cheers
same time yeah oh god no there's a
banana in there in hot sauce
[Music]
[Music]
it's okay no that ramen is crunchy
um is a consistency i didn't know ice
cream could have
put in
yeah definitely i mean
i thought hot sauce on ice cream could
be like a maybe because sometimes they
put cayenne pepper on ice cream
it's not it's not it's not even a lego
maybe it's a
it's a hell no it's a please never again
oh my gosh
um whatever what is this i think it's
sour cream
yeah sour cream i would like to take a
time this moment to talk to the internet
and let them know how important it is to
pick your friends
because had i picked the wrong partner
for this we would be eating an olive
avocado sundae
we wouldn't we're not going to savage
and we would be going home sick
mazel tov i don't know why i keep trying
to eat it it's ice cream in front of me
that's a problem
there you go palette cleanser
yeah i'll do the berries yeah all right
fantastic i thought we did an awesome
creation on our sunday
as we build it blind and it's going to
be living with me for at least the rest
of today
thanks for joining us on build it blind
you